where does confidence come from the
Army's latest recruitment campaign is
trying to persuade youngsters to turn
their backs on quick-fix lifestyle
messages from advertising and social
media okay
the Army has shrunk for the last nine
years and is now seven thousand men and
women short of its 82,000 target it's
pinning its hopes for 2020 on a new
message the confidence that lasts a
lifetime there's one place you'll find
that the whole sort of you know instant
likes you know love island body the you
know you can apply makeup for a night
whether you're a male or a female and it
only lasts for a 24-hour period or
whatever
is-is-is again to provoke a little bit
of conversation and debate and I think
that's really important to have that
conversation debate and what we're not
saying that that's a bad thing we just
said that what we can offer is something
that lasts a little bit longer which is
a confidence problems with recruitment
go back years this army attempt to climb
Everest in 2006 was supposed to boost
numbers but they didn't get to the top
and recruitment has fallen significantly
since one problem is only 10% of those
who apply make it through to basic
training that's one of the things the
Army is working on putting remedial
programs in place if you like to try and
improve people's educational start point
and also their physical fitness start
point that's good for individuals I
think that's good for society as well
the new recruitment video comes from
research suggesting teenagers lack
self-confidence most of those we showed
it to in Leeds were not inspired some
people might like need to go into the
army but for me I feel like I'm they see
it as giving you confidence opportunity
a career for life probably I could do
that in other places not the army it's
just a big commitment to be honest with
you a lot of the positions you are
kind of hire them for a few years I just
wanted the flexibility it's kind of
change my mind when I wanted to so the
army not for you there is no suggestion
that this new campaign will solve the
Army's recruitment problem whose could
be huge just six weeks the Ministry of
Defense will be hoping to win more money
from the Treasury in a defense review
later this year
Jared sub Sky News Leeds